i asked you when there was no sound how
does it feel knowing you're both loved
and admired by your core audience but
you also got a lot of people that
hate what you're doing how does that
feel i i it's humbling it's um i'm sort
of wit
i don't really focus on the fear and i
and i think that then one of the things
i read about this book american
muckraker is the is the sort of
characteristics inherent in in my
colleagues and myself is that we're sort
of very tunnel vision so we don't really
focus on those things we know that
they're there we take rational steps to
deal with them but we're kind of focused
on what we do
some tells me it doesn't bother you
though some tells me you're comfortable
with opposition
i i didn't ask for the opposition
sometimes i don't understand the
opposition
um but it's there and uh i don't let it
affect our decision-making so so would
you call yourself a whistleblower or a
is it a muck-raker muckraker is the term
i think is best defined us and some
people don't know what that means it it
means someone who publishes information
that the powerful people do not want
published versus publishing information
they give you to publish how different
is that than a whistleblower or is it is
much raker
somebody who goes and recruits other
whistleblowers as muckraker somebody
that goes against the institution
how would you explain the difference
between the two well i think a muckraker
is a
term
you know historically from 100 years ago
teddy roosevelt coined it
it could be all-encompassing um the
whistleblowers that we work with don't
are not my employees they don't i don't
uh pay them salaries we have people on
full-time staff muckraker is effectively
anybody who can
expose what's going on the real truth
the hidden the hidden truth
so it is an element of being a
whistleblower it is an element of
somebody who wants to expose people who
behind closed doors are playing
essentially the game of uh what do you
call it the the puppet masters you're
trying to expose some of those guys yes
we're trying to expose that with the
powerful people in a world where
the fbi and the new york times and
pharmaceutical companies and all these
they're just acting in concert
it takes kind of an independent
citizen group of people that are just
the ordinary folks to expose it yeah and
it's it's
the the concept of citizen journalism
is on fire right now where people are
becoming the journalists due to
this one weapon and tool that we all
have right here i don't know if you saw
this guy
that plays for manchester united the
soccer player what's the guy's name have
you seen the story with this guy what's
been happening to him so this guy pull
him up manchester united soccer player
uh a
soccer player it should pop up
uh there it is right there go to the
second one greenwood mason greenwood
there's a video of him
and an audio of his girlfriend recording
their conversation having sex it's such
a
weird and by the way he got fired i
believe they just let him go
and he's being accused for certain
things he she's saying i don't want to
do this and he's saying don't make me do
this and then there's videos of her
bleeding with like you know he hit her
in the face and next you know they let
her go meaning this thing is probably
one of the most scariest or most
powerful weapons that we have today so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you